So this tells us that there are actually two square roots for any number n.
There's the positive version, which of course squared gives us n but there's
also the negative version. Which, also 1 squared, gives us n. You will notice,
however, that although there's a negative sign written outside the negative
square root. There's not a positive sign written outside the positive version.
The positive version of the square root is implied to equal a positive number.
For example, if we wrote the square root of 64, with no sign symbol out in
front, this would be implied to equal positive 8. If we wanted to show that
negative 8 times itself equals 64 then we'll write the square root sign at 64
but we'd also need to put a negative sign out in front of it. The square root of
a number without the negative sign in front is called the principal square root
of that number. In this case, n. So, 8 is the principal square root of 64.